hey there welcome to the uplift the show
designed to lift you up for at least the
next 30 minutes you and me as well for
that matter we have a great cast of
characters for you today including a mom
who gives free hugs to total strangers
what's the reason behind her Mission
we'll explain also a little girl with a
rare condition and not much time to get
treatment what happened to make her
family's dream finally come true and an
award-winning artist that you have to
see in action to really believe plus we
meet two sisters who did not even know
the other existed until now that's the
moment what brought them together we'll
get into it also Jane Goodall recently
received a unique tribute and it's one
that our kids might like what is it
we'll show you all that plus our most
heartwarming videos of the week you're
watching see uplift
[Music]
all right
hey there I'm Tony decopo we do indeed
have a very good show for you today and
we are going to begin as we always do
with our most heartwarming videos of the
week starting with this one now you may
think it's a video of a waiter talking
to a family at a restaurant
but Mom there has no clue that the
waiter is actually her son he's a nurse
in Ireland and was not able to see his
family in the Philippines for three
years because of the pandemic that meant
he missed his dad's 75th birthday but he
made it home to surprise Mom on her 75th
birthday and as you can see she was
shocked that he was not really her
waiter when he uncovered his face she
was just brought to tears as you can
imagine 75th birthday Miss dads made it
back for moms lovely reunion there all
right last week was the first ever
International paramedics day and two
British paramedics tried to record a
special message in an effort to Mark the
occasion their attempts at filming a
video went like this
hello everybody
um
um welcome
good afternoon everyone my name is Dave
tomorrow paramedic at Luton and I'm
sitting here with Joe Carter all right
another permanent from Luton so we're
here to talk about International
paramedic day which is on the 8th of
July tell me Joe what does that mean to
you
what's it like in the paramedic
good afternoon everyone my name is Dave
tomorrow I'm a paramedic at Luton and
I'm sitting alongside my colleague Joe
Cartwright another paramedic from Luton
um and we're here to celebrate and
actually recognize the first ever
International paramedics day which is on
the 8th of July Joe tell me how did it
feel to be a paramedic it feels really
good to be embarrassed I don't know what
you saying that I can't stop saying if
it was scary I'm so sorry
oh uh you know it is one of those jobs
where I think you need to have a pretty
good sense of humor I love those guys uh
they have a good time in a very tough
career path all right we've got a
warning for you uh this next video it
may get a little bit loud
funny yes but not funny haha funny weird
[Music]
cue the dogs pawing at the TV and
Howling along with them now if you think
those two huskies are too loud think of
how their fellow dog Zoe feels about it
all Zoe has learned how to deal with
Nico and Jackson's howling just like we
would she wears headphones
[Music]
[Applause]
we got another dog video for you so
don't worry this one's a little bit
quieter
take a look Baker a 13 and a half year
old golden retriever
still dancing you got a compilation on
your screen right now of his dinner
dance and this compilation went viral
he uh he's a little older but age is not
slowing Baker down still got that
flexibility a lot more Nimble than I am
okay a toddler in Egypt made headlines
recently when a video of her falling
over and then asking for help went viral
you may Wonder now why that moment
gained such widespread attention well
it's because the little girl in the
video she's got a very rare disorder and
in fact she desperately needs treatment
and the strangers who saw her asking for
help they decided to pitch in in a very
big way Christina capititis has the
story
when a baby is born you often hear
parents wishing two things for their
child Above All Else happiness and
health and for the first six months of
her life rokaya Retta appeared a happy
healthy baby girl then unusual symptoms
started to present themselves so
rakaya's parents took her for testing
and learned that she has what's called
spinal muscular atrophy a rare
degenerative neuromuscular disorder that
in his most severe cases claims patients
lives before their second birthday and
those with moderate cases can survive
into adulthood but they're often left
unable to walk as the condition robs
them of control of their bodies there
are drugs to treat SMA in young children
but the most effective one is often
referred to as the most expensive drug
on Earth its price tag is 2.1 million
dollars and it has to be administered
before a child turns two by the time
rokaya's parents were faced with that
Herculean feet her birthday was just a
couple weeks away so rakaya's family for
help and found it in a non-profit
organization called The Power of social
media which has more than 120 volunteers
devoted to helping people with medical
issues through the power of crowdfunding
they analyze data to maximize donations
and they distributed photos and videos
of rakaya's daily struggles to move
people around the world
in one video rakaya Falls and screams
help me help me and help strangers did
in just three weeks they reached their
goal thanks to countless donations most
small just a dollar or two some kids
even writing that they had emptied their
piggy banks for the cause a testament
yes to the power of social media but
also to the human heart amounting to a
very big miracle for a very lucky little
girl
why they called The Uplift coming up we
introduce you to an artist you'll have
to see to believe plus a mom who gives
out hugs to strangers and she started a
movement in doing it what's the reason
behind her free hugs to total strangers
we'll explain
[Music]
thank you
no matter how prepared you are dealing
with a natural disaster like a wildfire
can end up feeling very isolating
there's a group of people who have gone
through it before though and they want
to help others CBS Sacramento is Andrew
habner has the story
it's not if it's when Janine cicchini
was driving home from Rio Vista and saw
the plume of smoke it was trauma
the feeling all too familiar to
Residents in this area people who live
in the Foothills are very rare fire
they're very accustomed to it and
they're always as we call it ready set
go close bedding but that feeling has
taken a toll people are petrified in
response to the fear of that unknown
residents took to social media to help
one another we created these fire groups
for people to have a place to come
together and vent and share resources
and kind of help each other residents
post fire updates on site While others
former Caldor fire evacuees provide tips
on what to take with you and what's
important in your first evacuation the
last time we were evacuating people were
really worried about things at least
people I was talking with and this time
they're like I just want to get my kids
and my livestock and loved ones out
safely
priorities there you have it all right
our next story needs little introduction
it's about an award-winning artist
that's also a pig
I'm not kidding here's Adrianne Moore
with the story
I already love your work it's beautiful
this pot-bellied pig Caso is proof that
cloven Hooves carry a lot of creativity
the first series that she did was her
blue period so that's kind of where the
pig Casa came from then she does a
really pretty kind of pinkish red so
that's kind of for Georgia O'Keefe phase
if you will two-year-old Charlotte is
the animal artist behind nearly a dozen
abstract pieces this is a hundred
percent unique original Charlotte art
[Music]
using kid-friendly non-toxic paints her
owner Jenny manueli sprinkles Cheerios
and granola around the canvas then lets
the nearly 300 pounder go to work she's
got Unique Style and each one is so
different but it's just fun it's super
fun to see her create something and see
the results and those results don't
stink Charlotte's work recently scored
some big recognition earning her blue
ribbons for first place at both the
motherload and Calaveras County fairs it
brought tears to my eyes just because
the points getting across the message is
getting across this is for fun this is
for Smiles this is for inspiration a
first of its kind win for a four-legged
contestant with skills so popular she
now has her own Instagram or in this
case insta ham account I know what she's
brought into my life if I can share that
with people that's that's what it's
about
I think my favorites are the ones that
still have the granola and Cheerio stuck
to them
perfect uh Picasso good name all right
moving on to our next Story Soccer Star
Carson Pickett recently made head
history rather during her first game
with the U.S women's national team now
Pickett who was born without her left
forearm and left hand became the first
person with a limb difference as they
call it to play on the team here's what
she said about finding out she was going
into the game
it's been incredible I think coming in
um at 28 seems Seems old sometimes but
hey with so many young players it's just
awesome to see the youth that's coming
up and the veterans that are here and
it's such a good mix and I felt like I
came in at the right time I was I came
in earlier I honestly think I would be
so nervous and things like that and I
was just able to come in and play and
just be around honestly great teammates
Bravo you can find more of our
heartwarming stories on our Facebook
page if you want to know the address on
the internet that's facebook.com
slash uplift news
coming up Jane Goodall has been a
world-renowned conservationist for
decades now and she recently received a
new honor you might not expect but it's
something your kids might like
plus we introduce you to two sisters who
didn't even know the other existed until
just very recently tell you what brought
them together after the break stick
around
[Music]
there are a lot of families that get
together during the summer time but this
next pair of sisters recently met for
the very first time in any season any
season of the year CBS Minnesota was
there for that meeting and Brent Clayton
picks up the story
all right
Let's Help an airport pickup has high
stakes when you've never met I hope they
didn't get lost
don't say that higher still when it's
your sister so weird and it doesn't even
feel real highly misfelt lives in Eden
Prairie she took a 23andMe DNA ancestry
test over Christmas the results a sister
suji Dufresne from New York neither knew
the other existed until a few months ago
Sunday the much anticipated meeting it
was so much shorter
I just felt like so just overwhelmed
with happiness and just all good suji is
27. three years older than eilee both
were adopted from South Korea just
months old in a way unknowingly living
parallel lives seeing her in person she
looks even more like me than in the
pictures so I didn't even think that was
possible I had this kind of like back
and forth of the feelings of is this
real but it also felt like very meant to
be
a reunion 24 years in the making that
could have easily never happened it's
wild and I'm a swiper I could have
easily deleted that because I'm just I'm
one to go through my emails and clean it
up really quick so
it's just unbelievable relief for what
once was a struggle well I considered
that I was an alien at points in my
teenage years because I just didn't
think anybody could be related to me I
think now I'm just I have a sister
another sister and
um I just I don't know it's like a new
sister a new friend it's exciting and
suji's son has a new aunt all I've ever
known uh genetics wise is my son when he
was born that was like my big moment of
I have somebody that is related to me
and I know is related to me so it just
feels like an expansion a connection
always there now made real I can't wait
we have a whole list yes of what we're
gonna do we have a bucket list of wasted
time that we gotta fill yes
love that story
Jane Goodall is the subject of our next
story she's known around the world for
being a Pioneer in science and she
recently received an honor that you
might not expect and one that your kids
might really enjoy Caitlin O'Kane has
the story
it's been more than 60 years since Jane
Goodall first immersed herself in the
world of chimpanzees at 26 years old she
was a Pioneer for women in science and
an inspiration to girls everywhere I was
selected by Louis Leakey because I was
female he thought that I'd be more
patient out in the field
and since young girls began reading
about my early life and my career with
the gyms many many many of them have
told me that they went into conservation
or animal behavior because of me but her
Love of Animals started long before she
became a conservationist I was born
loving and being fascinated by animals
you know and because I loved animals
people gave me animal toys now good all
is inspiring kids with her own toy a
Barbie
well I don't know if I expected it to
happen you know the original Barbie's
little frilly clothes and very girly
girly and I thought that because my
career has always interested young
people but to have a doll that was a
doll about me would be would be a good
thing good or may not have expected to
become a Barbie at 88 years old but it's
not just any doll it's made out of
recycled plastic and Barbie is
partnering with the Jane Goodall
foundation and its roots and shoots
program which inspires young people to
protect others animals and the
environment no the main message is every
day you live you make an impact on the
planet and you get to choose what sort
of impact you make and even small kids
size impacts can lead to something big
it was a little boy of seven in Burundi
and I've given a talk to the school and
he came up to me and he said if I pick
up a piece of trash every day it will
make a difference won't it and I said
yes it will I suppose you persuade 10 of
your friends to pick up a piece of
rubbish every day he said oh that would
make that would really make a difference
and then they could all get 10 of their
friends couldn't they so that's it the
cumulative effect of small actions can
lead to big change she's been inspiring
young people for decades now newer
Generations will get a whole new
experience with Jane Goodall I sincerely
hope that it will help to create more
interest and Fascination in the natural
world because hopefully you know they'll
if they don't know they'll learn more
about me and that will get them
interested it doesn't really matter
whether they have a career in
conservation as long as they live
conservation in their daily lives
rooting for you Jane it's a great
addition to your many tributes over a
long and successful Life as a
conservationist all right coming up
we're going to the mom who made it her
mission to hug perfect strangers what's
behind her movement free hugs for moms
[Music]
foreign
just about everyone could use a good hug
sometimes and for some people a hug can
make a huge impact that is why one mom
has made it her mission to make
strangers feel loved with hugs from Mom
David begno you guessed it has the story
Oklahoma City had a Pride Fest that was
filled with all the music rainbow flags
and love you could want to find thanks
in part to Sarah Cunningham happy Pride
baby and her group free mom hugs you
have moms and dads and friends and
allies by the thousands my parents are
not supportive of me being gay so it
just felt good to have somebody say that
but Cunningham who grew up a devout
Christian
did not always embrace the lgbtq plus
community in fact when her son Parker
now 33 years old came out to her when he
was a teenager the mother of two
rejected him I really thought that he
was going to burn in hell for eternity
and I thought if I accepted this about
him that made me just as much of a
sinner than he is you never forget I
mean things that were said are things
that were done but it's through kind of
telling our story together that I think
has really helped us
um just understand the journey better so
many kids who were gay don't even have
the courage to say it to their mother he
did and you still didn't welcome it
that's not to apply no I understand it's
to tell people watching
to not do it he was sharing the most
tender intimate part of himself
and I denied him that still haunts her
the guilt that he probably felt and I
certainly do now and we've worked
through a lot of things so but you can't
get rid of those memories she went
through some pretty deep soul searching
that is what led to a change of heart I
could not reconcile what I learned as a
loving God
who created my son that he would cast
him into hell was there a moment where
you said to him I hear you and I accept
you
Parker and his friend were here and we
were in the backyard and his friend was
sharing a story and I could see
self-harm marks on his arm and he shared
about how he had been alien alienated
from his family
in his church
group and it was there that
I just felt such unconditional love
for that person I hardly knew and she
never forgot it in 2015 she started free
mom hugs and she's been hell-bent on
showing up for the lgbtq plus Community
consistently you could have helped serve
food you could have marched in the
parade like why a hug that's a really
good question I'm a hugger and it
allowed me to give love in a way that a
mother should and it has evolved from
there in 2018 Cunningham took to social
media writing if you need a mom to
attend your same-sex wedding because
your biological mom won't call me I'm
there how many people called you people
from all around the world
so I'll show up too I'll Stand in really
yeah all over the world Cunningham has
officiated or served as a stand-in mom
at more than a dozen weddings have you
lost friends doing this yes family yes
have they come back only when someone
they love comes out oh and that's all
right
when I was
the mom like me then I needed someone
who shared my faith to tell me it's okay
to search the matter out
Melissa Williams turned to Cunningham
after learning that her daughter was a
lesbian
Williams is now the co-leader of the
Texas chapter of free mom hugs
happy Pride y'all last weekend she drove
the two hours to Oklahoma City to think
of some hugs
for Herod Aspen whose mother passed away
before she came out the connection is
one that she longed for having somebody
who represents a mom just being
accepting and loving extremely important
and there's people like me and others
that I know it just one hug means
everything it makes my eyes water when I
think of the love and the outpouring of
just Community this is what it's all
about in the nearly 10 years since she
gave her first mom hug Sarah Cunningham
is now traveling parts of this country
with her son shedding her shame
forgetting her fear and joining in in
the joy you feel loved very loved
love has come full circle over the
course of this interview you have said
in a roundabout way about three times
the Lord said to me
and it's occurring to me that
you got all twisted up about what people
said the Lord meant yes rather than
directly what the Lord was telling you
to do yeah and that's what I couldn't
reconcile yeah that's sweet I never
heard it said that way thank you David
you can always count on David beg now
and you can always count on the uplift
that is our show I'm confident it
brightened your day and lifted you up
and if it didn't as I always say
re-watches are free I'm gonna Scout some
more good news see you next week
foreign